I'm Phil Bowsher the director of Life Sciences
and Healthcare here at posit I'm going to help
moderate the session today we're going to be
doing some q a you'll see that popping up on
the right hand side we'll also be doing
Q a through slido we'll share that link
we'll also be doing questions coming in from
YouTube so lots of exciting uh questions coming
in and we'll tackle those at the end of the
session today over the last 10 to 15 minutes
I'm very excited to bring to you today the eighth
installment of our life sciences series previously
we highlighted BMS Merck GSK navarros Johnson
and Johnson and others you can find these posit
webinars linked below um from my team and today we
have an exciting sequel to our July 2019 webinar
by rosh and genintech that highlighted the role
of R and Drug Discovery research and development
and today we're going to highlight the awesome
work being done by Roche and Genentech and
shifting to an open source Backbone in clinical
trials this amazing work is being led by James
Black the senior director of insights engineering
and data and statistical Sciences will kick off
the presentation today with Karen Martin the
r enablement lead and statistical programmer
we'll then pass it over to Thomas needman
code collaboration lead and data scientists
as well as the technical lead for the Admiral
r package will then end with ningling people
on product lead and product development and data
Sciences Roshan Genentech is such an inspiration
from the Legacy with Robert gentleman to the
contribution and countless hours to the open
source drug development Community a true load
star in our space working with other pharmas
and contributing to efforts such as Admiral
and the pharmac the mmrn package the FDA pilot
submissions bioconductor our core our tables and
countless other projects for the community over
10 people contributed workshops or talks at the
RN Pharma conference in November and you can find
those videos on the RN Pharma YouTube page linked
below and it's with great honor and pleasure to
bring this session to the community today and now
I'll pass it over to Karen to kick off the webinar
so um I'll explain to that let's wait a minute
okay great um yeah so thanks so much Phil for that
intro it's um really great that uh our efforts are
being seen in the wider Community um so today
um yeah myself Thomas and ning are going to
talk about the uh next steps we're making at rush
um uh the steps we're kind of been making already
and what's happening this year so I'm gonna start
by just providing an introduction as to uh what it
is exactly we're talking about in terms of
Shifting to an open source backbone um and
kind of why we've got to this point why we've
made the uh decision right now to switch that
um then Thomas is gonna get into what that looks
like in terms of the platform we're building to
do our work on and the tools um that we're going
to use on that platform uh then he's going to hand
back to me and I'm going to talk about how we're
getting our talent base ready to switch from one
language to another and also how we're kind of
trying to move to a different culture in how
we approach data science in general and then we're
going to finish with ning who's going to go into a
bit more detail about how this business transition
is actually going to look like in practice
um so let me start by just setting the scene
a little bit for what I'm talking about
um Phil kind of allude to this already
um but Rush is obviously a really big
company and today we're not here talking
for the whole of Rush all of us are from a
particular department at rush called PD data
Sciences um if you don't know what that is
that's that's fine I'll explain it a little bit
now our basic job is to report clinical trials
the rush obviously conducts loads of different
clinical trials all over the world to gather
data on the effectiveness of the different
products we create to help fight diseases
and our role in PD data Sciences is to make sure
all that data is gathered accurately following
the protocols we've set out and to summarize
it um so that we have a good picture of how
these drugs work so as you might imagine this
is a really important job it's really vital
that we get this right that we have the safety
and efficacy data to be accurate and that we
can share it with Regulators as soon as possible
because as the the more quickly we get this data
summarized and presented the quicker we can get
drugs to patients to help them fight illnesses
so what's our goal then um so fundamentally our
goal in PD data Sciences is to shift towards
a language agnostic framework and what I mean by
that is we're moving away from having one solution
for how we do our programming for clinical
trials we want the ability to be flexible and
move towards the best language for solving our
problems and our expectation is that in future
there won't be necessarily one solution for for
solving it we'll be picking the best problem
from the marketplace so most of what we're talking
about today is the first step on this journey but
we will be alluding to the kind of The Wider ideas
of this as well and that first step I think has
already been mentioned a bit in the advertising
for this seminar which is that this year
um uh from Quarter Two novel studies we'll be
using r as their core data science tool there will
be analyzing our data using R primarily I will say
that this is definitely novel studies like we're
not we're not doing a cliff said thing where we
switch everything to R overnight um because but
it is a big change and we expect that over the
next few years we'll have more and more studies
using our core data science tool until we're using
it as our primary tool across all of our studies
um and this as I say is the first step
in this journey where in future we can
move flexibly in the future so R isn't
our destination it's part of a journey
that allows us to move towards what the
best data science tool is in the future
um so just a bit of context setting for this
if you're not super familiar with Pharma
um farmer in general um has typically used
commercial software to support filings um
I think that's been true across the industry and
it's been true for a really long time that's kind
of the way we've been doing things um and there's
lots of historical reasons I won't get into there
but it does mean that our talent and tools are
at least historically really reflected this you
know we have a code base that's being built up
over 20 30 years and a talent base that's been
using that code base for this time so that's kind
of just a highlight why this shift is big for us
um so why are we doing this um there's loads of
different reasons that have inspired us to make
this change I'm going to highlight a few today
but I wouldn't say that this is an exhaustive list
um when it comes to R in particular R is
something that had been used at rush for a
while but I would say the kind of wedge product
that got it used a lot more at PD data Sciences
in particular was our shiny our shiny really
offered capabilities we didn't have already
in the tools we had the ability to make these
interactive apps using Code so so quickly and
simply really proved a really attractive offer
and really encouraged us to start using our at
least behind the scenes in clinical studies and
in fact one of the earliest our packages that
was built in-house to support this was a package
called teal which Thomas is going to talk about
about later that this is now open source you
can follow that URL to go to to see that package
right now and this was an in-house solution for
standardized Channel apps so we had this kind
of uh justification for why we wanted to start
using our more and then there were a few other
things that really started to weigh off towards
thinking about moving towards R um one was just
about uh the talent base generally speaking when
we're recruiting new graduates they're much more
likely to know these open source tools such as r
or indeed python than they are commercial software
um but the final point which I think is um a bit
more future looking is we wanted to go open the
source and the reason for this is we think open
source offers loads of opportunities for how we
work um the first is just around getting latest
developments more rapidly typically if there's a
new statistical method used to analyze data that
will often be implemented in r first of all so
if we want to get access to those more quickly to
provide better results then we should be using our
the other is we knew we wanted to go language
agnostic we knew we wanted that ability to switch
between languages and we know that open source
is going to make that easier because with no
proprietary format it's usually easier to switch
between contacts and the obvious example of this
is the ability to switch between R and python
there's been a lot of effort to make those two
languages talk to each other nicely and the last
one which is one I'm really excited about and
Thomas is going to talk about a bit more in
a minute is the ability to collaborate with
external Partners so up until you know a few
years ago all of our code was created entirely
in-house it wasn't really possible for us to work
with people from outside of Russia but if we go
open the source we suddenly have this ability to
get the inputs of people from across the industry
which I think is in the long run going to lead to
much more efficient and better code and ultimately
better outcome fast and for our patients so
hopefully that's been a good introduction as
to why we're doing what we're doing and now I'm
going to pass over to Thomas he's going to talk
a bit about uh the as I say the environment
and the tools we're using in that environment
thank you so much Karen so then let's talk about
the building blocks of this kind of modern data
science platform we set out to create which is
really focused on open source as its backbone
so first of all I would just like to quickly dive
a bit more detail into the requirements we MPD
data scientists have for our day-to-day work and
generally we can separate our task into either the
regulatory side of things or the exploratory side
of things and on the regulatory side of things
there's really four main deliverables we need to
create the first one is called sdtm so sctm is an
industry standard for the data we collect the
clinical trials so regardless of how the data
is collected in the end when you submit it to
the health authority it has to be in this data
um standard such that it's harmonized across
companies next up we have the analysis or atom
data sets and here you take the sctm data sets
as source and then you transform them in a way
that suits your analysis Downstream so as a quick
example imagine you collect a questionnaire which
has 10 questions and an overall summary score so
the 10 questions you would have in your satn data
because that's the raw data as collected but then
you would calculate the summary overall score as
part of your atom transformation next up we need
to perform a bunch of statistical analyzes and
that can be something as simple and descriptive
as counting Adverse Events or something much
more complex for example fitting a survival
model or fitting a mixed measures repeat model
and finally we need to put those statistical
analysis into an easily digestible format and
that's generally either tables listings or graphs
and all these four components combined make up
the packages that we submit to health authorities
such as the US FDA in order to get Market approval
for novel Therapeutics we are working on so
this is really at the core of our business
but of course we also have the exploratory set
of things and here really it's highly context
context dependent what we need to perform
and therefore we need flexible tools and
really the best tool for the job so having
an open source background where you have
access to multiple languages for example
is really a good thing in this context
we also need to consider that there's novel data
modalities um we're getting more and more for
example Imaging data is becoming rapidly and more
on our trials digital biomarker oh mix data Etc
so it's not just the classical rectangular data
anymore which we use to analyze in our commercial
software and finally um we want not only to enable
our data scientists to easily explore our data but
also people who don't work in data science our
colleagues in safety or clinical scientists and
we want to really enable them to easily explore
their data and do so in a reproducible manner such
that they don't always have to come back to us as
data science and we have this long feedback loop
and really all of this combined necessity that we
created a Next Generation statistical Computing
platform where we could really perform all these
analyzes and this is where ocean comes into play
our one Central analytics environment which is the
home for both our exploratory and Regulatory work
so ocean is built in the cloud on AWS and it's
a language agnostic platform which right now
supports our python as well as SAS for our Legacy
work but it is easily extendable because it's
based on Docker containers so if you spin up a
container with for example Julia in it suddenly
you would have access to that language as
well for Version Control we are using git
and gitlab and we're not only using that for
our packages we develop internally but it's
actually will be there to store the code for
all our studies so if on a study you program
a particular atom data set or an adverse event
table the code for that will be stored on gitlab
next up and this is really a big change even
though it sounds somewhat silly but we moved
away from this proprietary format set 7B that that
used to be um the only format really that we used
to store our serious data and instead we opted
for an open source format called parquet which
is developed by the Apache foundation and it's a
binary format for handling rectangular data and
it's highly efficient in both reading and writing
and it has Surplus already very well so far
we have an internal rstudio connect server
as part of this platform where we house our
exploratory shiny apps and we have a validated our
package repository so while typically you would
install packages from cran internally we use this
validated package repository and you would find a
lot of packages that you know from cran such
as ggplot2 or D player over there as well as
well as our own open source packages we develop
plus internal packages and it goes through and
our own internal really streamlined and efficient
validation process which is called Auto validate
then we are using another open source tool called
snake mate to orchestrate our production runs and
snake make is very clever in a way because it
creates a directed acyclical graph of all the
artifacts that you need to create so think
of your sctms your atoms your tlgs and then
it really paralyzes as much as possible taking
dependencies into account so what used to take
maybe a whole day for example to run everything
for a final clinical study report now is done in
a matter of hours if not minutes and finally
ocean is the tool as the home of our next-gen
tools for clinical reporting and I will spend the
rest of my part talking about these next-gen tools
so the first one of those is called Oak and Oak
is our solution for automating sdcm mapping so
sctm mapping used to take a considerable amount
of our time and it was a rather labor intensive
process that was also somewhat mundane so we
really opted to streamline this by creating an
automation solution and driven by metadata and
our global data standards at Roche Oak can now
automate around 80 of sctm domains with around 22
reusable mapping algorithms and this in turn then
really saved us a lot of time we've seen already
efficiency gains by at least 50 percent so this
is really huge and finally it's actually a fairly
simple tool to use because it's at the end of the
day a single r package you interact with plus a
web app but that being said under the hood it's
somewhat more complex because it has to interact
with several systems and that's actually why it's
called the Oak Garden and the first component
of this Garden is called pistol and honeybee
so really what you have to think about is we
have a metadata repository at Roche which is
the graph database and inside that we store the
mappings from the raw data as we collected to
this sctm standard in a machine readable
format and that's really key here because
that makes it then easy for are for example
to query this information and make use of it
next up we have our sctm spec Creator which is
called mint so this is a web application in react
to create the study specific sctm mappings and
when I say that um really most of it at least
80 percent from what I had on the previous slide
should already be automated there if you adhere to
standards and then in this app you have additional
leader functionality to add any non-standard
mappings if for example you connect somewhat a new
data endpoints which are not yet in our standards
all of this is then saved in a repository
which is called saffron and again in a
machine readable format and in the Json such a
definitely queried down the road in R and very
importantly any non-standards you would Define
in the mid application you would save in saffron
such that you that you can reuse these
non-standard mappings across different studies
and finally we have the actual data transformation
engine which is called Oak and this is the r
package people in the end would use and really
it's a very streamlined process you fetched all
this metadata from saffron basically and
then you have a single function called per
satm domain and given all this metadata
it will then output your sdgm data sets
so the Oak Garden is not open source and the
reason for that being is that it's fairly tailored
towards our internal Roche architecture but that
being said the overall principle is really broadly
applicable to anyone who has to map sdtn data sets
which is also the reason why we're in active talks
with the cdisk open source Alliance to create
a proof of concept in which we would use C Dash
rather than our own internal data collection
standard as a source and if that's something
you and your organization are interested in to
collaborate potentially then please reach out I
certainly have heard a lot of questions regarding
sctm and R at iron farmer and so this might be
a good opportunity to reach out and maybe a
good collaboration can speak in all of that
so we covered the first pillar of our regulatory
reporting site and now it's time for the second
which is the atom data sets and here our solution
is called Admiral which is an open source modular
toolkit for Adam dataset Creation in r and what
is really unique about Admiral is that unlike
other packages we developed and which are now
open source this did not start out as a closed
Source internal project and then later on got
open sourced really from the start of it we
collaborated with another organization namely
GSK um to hit the ground running and build
something that would be usable not only for Rush
purposes but really for the industry as a whole
and I think it's fair to say that this has
been quite a success we certainly want to
use this kind of model of collaboration going
forward and and when I say success I think one
metric that really hits that home is that what
started out as this collaboration between two
organizations to create one r package now is
actually an ecosystem of our packages which are
developed by seven pharmaceutical organizations
in total so in addition to Admiral we now have
Admiral uncle where Amgen and Bristol mile
script joined us with their oncology expertise
there is the Admiral opta package which nobody's
um and rosh are working all together and finally
GSK is collaborating with Pfizer and Jonathan
Johnson on this Admiral vaccines package
and if you and your organization are interested in
leveraging R and Adam and Admiral for adding data
set transformation and you have expertise in a
particular therapeutic area again please reach out
um we would really love to
see this ecosystem growing
next up I want to talk about our statistical
engineering team which is really working
at this intersection of biostatistics and
statistical or software engineering actually
so this team really focuses on accelerating the
adoption of Novel statistical methods so really
all the cutting-edge stuff that comes out of
Academia and trying to implement that as software
and so far this has been mainly focused on our
packages um and also occasionally Stan or C plus
plus have been used in the background but the team
is really open also to other languages for example
Julia basically anything that is open source
and a viable solution for statistical computing
and really important to highlight is this
this team is not only working at Roche alone
but it's part of a larger industry-wide effort
namely the software engineer working group of
the American statistical Association where not
only rush and other pharmaceutical companies
but also academic institutions jointly work
together to basically Implement The Cutting
Edge of Statistics in software and here's
just a couple of examples of packages the
statistical engineering team has worked on the
mrmm package down there is actually the first
one that came out of this software engineering
working group and another one I would like to
highlight is this RBM I package for reference
based model amputation which won an award by
the Royal statistical Society last year
once again this has been a collaborative
effort in this case between Roche and the
University of bath so an academic Institution
so finally on the regulatory side of things
we have the creation of our tables listings
and graphs and really when we started doing
that in R the G part the graph part was the
easy one we just used gtplot2 it was the best tool
available for the job it still is in our opinion
um and it was certainly also a big reason um
why to shift to R in the first place having
such a good tool readily available however the T
side of things the tables especially if you look
a couple years back and there was not such
a really good solution out there so what we
did is we created our own which is called our
tables and our tables really has an expressive
and modern API for table generation and R and
very importantly it is built from the ground up
with the needs of clinical reporting in mind
and we think that this is really key because
the kinds of tables you do in this space tend
to be much more hierarchical and complex than
say a typical table you would find in an
academic journal or even on some websites
right now our table supports outputting
tables in plain text word PowerPoint PDF
HTML and the version on GitHub the development
version right now also added RTF support
and this is an open source package which
you can install from either GitHub or cred
something that is working in tenant with our
tables is turn and it's really a complement
that focuses around the summary statistics because
you can think of it as bridging um the statistical
analysis you perform for example with one of
the packages we've seen on the previous slide
and then actually getting them to display in the
table and this is yet again an open source package
which is readily available for you also to use and
check out the the final piece on that kind of tlg
side of things is Chevron and this is really about
streamlining our processes even further so when we
started out doing tables in R we had an internal
tlg catalog which looked something like this so
this is a particular event table and you can see
it's just kind of a code dump you would copy paste
um into your study folder and then use but really
copy pasting is not a good solution so we opted
for something uh sort of template based and
right now you can basically create the same
table by using the Chevron run function
indicating the template you want to use
and then feeding in your data and off you go so
further a further gain and efficiency in that way
so finally let's talk also about
the exploratory side of things
um so I mentioned in the beginning we want to
enable our non-data scientist colleagues to
also easily and importantly reproducibly analyze
their clinical trial data so we set out um on this
journey and said that our Chinese would be really
a good solution for that however we did have a
problem which is how do we actually get our 600 or
so data scientists who are not shiny developers to
build these exploratory apps in the first place
we did not want to train all of these 600 people
to become a sort of shiny gurus instead what we
opted for is to create this framework called teal
which Kieran already mentioned in the beginning
and this framework really centers around reusable
modules and it really abstracts away a lot of the
complexities of building shiny apps from scratch
you don't actually have to care so much about
the UI as well as the server logic in the modules
you would readily adopt from a catalog this is
an example of a very simple app created using
teal and you can see on the top you have all these
tabs and each of the steps represents a particular
module so in this case it's a demographic table
module and what all measures have in common is
that in the center you have a display in this
case it's a table but it could also be a plot
and then on the left in addition you have this
encoding panel where you can kind of customize
what you see in this table for example here you
could select different variables to be displayed
so that's all the module specific part and
as I said we have a large catalog I think
even over 100 modules readily available for our
internal people and also for you because this is
open source to use but then the teal framework
itself also provides a couple of goodies that
work across all modules the first one of which
is this filter panel you see here on the right so
depending on which data is used in a particular
module it would list out a data set on top and
then you have the ability to select any variable
out of these data sets to drill down the data so
in this case we have a particular subgroup based
up on ADSL but if you imagine this would be some
kind of adverse event analysis you could easily
filter down for let's say serious Adverse Events
next up you have this reporter functionality and
this is a really neat one anything that you create
in any of these modules you can add to a shopping
basket sort of and then at the end of the day you
can go to the card and check out by exporting a
PDF report or a PowerPoint report and which would
then contain everything that you added to the card
so maybe a demographic table a couple of Mile plot
a response table whatever you may wish and finally
we have this show R code button functionality and
this is really key for us because that enables
the reproducible nature of teal because unlike
Tableau for example or Spotfire which are also
great tools to visualize data and drill down and
this is really a hundred percent reproducible
because if you click the button you will get a
complete R script including loading all packages
loading all data that is needed filtering the data
as you have in the filter panel here and then
reproducing the exact display that you see here
and that's really we think um a key for us so I
already mentioned this has been open source since
last year and the code is available on GitHub for
you to look at and also to install it from there
we have two sample apps which are publicly
available and the previous picture I showed
is one of those so definitely check those
out and actually teal has been used in an
R submission pilot to the FDA which is quite
an exciting development kind of instead of the
static tlg submitting a shiny app and there will
be more communication about that in the future
we have an upcoming webinar around teal at the
end of February where we will dive deep into
this particular tool for an hour or so and finally
we are looking for collaborators to develop this
framework further and I think that really goes
to all the tools that we've shown here kind of
in the spirit of the open source Community
where we take a lot of the great stuff that
other peoples have put out there we also want
to put the packages we develop out there and
collaborate with others to develop them further
and finally I would just like to mention that this
everything sort of I said is part of this larger
effort in the industry called the farmers where
different pharmaceutical companies come together
and develop our packages for end-to-end clinical
reporting that's really a great development which
we really hope and further gains traction this
year and the years to come and with that being
said here and I hand it back to you foreign
so yeah um Thomas has spent some time um
talking about um the sort of setup of how
we're going to do our rush so we've kind of
uh it's not all finished with very close to
finish you know it's a work in progress where
we have this environment we're going to work
and we have this tool base and certainly both
of those are going to continuously evolve over
time but we have a good idea of what we're
doing there and we've prevented that now
um but the other piece that we really can't forget
about when it comes to moving to a new language
is looking at our talent base making sure that
they're ready for this change and it definitely is
a big change you know it's not just about shifting
to R we're changing the environment we're working
in we're changing the tools we're using conversion
control so there's a lot of things for our talent
to learn and we need to make sure that they're
supported so what I'm going to talk about for the
next 10 minutes or so is just about some of the
measures we're taking to support everyone and this
is all you know this is a work in progress this is
something we're learning with as we're going and
certainly I expect to be giving uh future talks in
a year's time where we talk about what worked and
what doesn't but here's at least some of our ideas
that we're kind of throwing out there right now
so just thinking for a second about who we have
working in PD data Sciences there's a real mix
of uh different people here we have people who've
been in the industry for 20 or 30 years and have
never coded an r at all so they have a wealth of
experience in clinical trials but they don't have
much experience in r in particular or get as well
and then we have uh people who are our experts
and we've got a lot of people who've joined the
company more recently who um as I kind of alluded
to earlier have this our experience and haven't
had the opportunity to apply it in in the context
of clinical report now the other challenge we have
is that not everyone's transitioning to r at the
same time so again this is something I mentioned
in the intro that um we're not you know we're not
moving every single person to our uh all at once
we're doing it in a phased way and that's good
from a management point of view but it does mean
that you can't just give everyone training one
day and expect them to be able to apply it the
next day and the other thing um that I think is
really important when it when you think about
transitioning to a new language it's not about
just learning kind of how to use that language
it's also about being fluent in that language
um we really want our programmers to start
being able to know what good our code looks
like not just be able to throw something
together that just about works [Music]
so as I say I'm going to go through
some of the solutions we've looked at
um for dealing with these issues um so the big
one I think is around helping guide our users
so because of all those challenges we have doing
active live training isn't always going to be
possible realistically in terms of resource
restraints and the fact that everyone's not
transitioning at once it doesn't make sense to
do live training certainly something will do
but we need people to be able to do self-study
and the problem with self-study is that if you
just get put someone in a room and tell them
to learn a subject they might be able to do it
but it's going to be challenging they're not
going to know where to start necessarily and
in particular that you know they might go on
a journey that helps them a bit but isn't as
guided as it should be so we've been looking at
a few different ways to make this more effective
the first idea is um to work out what people
don't know um often when we've been sending
out initial surveys on people's knowledge on
subjects we do in a kind of granular way we say
you know how long have you been programming this
language how good do you think you're on it and
self-assessment on that level can be helpful but
it's often true particularly when you're starting
a subject that you kind of you don't know what
you don't know so you you there may be gaps in
your knowledge and you're just not aware of
them because you're not familiar enough with
the language and certainly uh for those of you who
are familiar with r there's lots of pitfalls when
it comes to the complexity of how R works that
if you've only starting off with r you're not
going to necessarily know about so that's what the
data science profile does it breaks all of these
categories into discrete topics and then Builds
assertions on kind of knowledge we'd expect people
to know to be considered proficient in that topic
so I've got a screenshot which is an example here
forget and it's got a collection of different
things I might expect as basic knowledge when
you're starting in get and basically this is all
based on self-assessment so it's not we're not
trying to catch people out here we're not trying
to trap anyone we want an honest uh reflection of
where they are and that helps them to understand
where they need to focus their learning on
so the next step is giving them the resources
to um fill those gaps that they have and one
important thing uh we've kind of thought
about if we don't really want to reinvent
the wheel what I mean by that is there can be a
Temptation when you've got some time the ability
to create training materials to go ahead and
just start making training resources without
thinking maybe this resource exists already
there's a huge amount of material online both
free and available via commercial license and
some of it is great um the challenge that a new
learner has is they don't necessarily know how
to direct themselves in this so we've already
got a bit of a start and they know the kind of
topics they want to work on but even then what
are the best resources for them to use and what
order should they be progressing through them
so what we've built for this is an in-house
solution which we're calling the data science
university and what this is is it's a tool to
create existing materials so what we do and
we've got an example here is we build learning
paths on a particular topic so this is a good
coding in our topic where we pick out we pick
that into discrete topic so again that link
to that data science profile seeing where your
gaps are and in each one we provide material that
we think is of high quality for learning about
that subject and again that may be an in-house
training that we've created but it could well be
a great resource that's available for free online
um so that the other thing I wanted to
mention as well is obviously a couple of
these things are in-house and you may be
curious about some of the material we're
producing at rush well I wanted to take a
little opportunity to do a sneaky advert
for something that's coming out very soon
on Coursera we've actually been building
um a genentec based course called making
data science work for clinical reporting
um this is actually going to be part of a wider
specialization and it's going to look at how
we think data science should be done in the
context of clinical reporting so this course
is literally being beta tested this week so I'm
really hopeful that it's going to be out either
this month or early in February so look out for
that if you're interested in the kind of material
we're producing around learning how to use data
science in the context of clinical reporting
so when it comes to making uh training resources
um one thing that I think is really key
um that's kind of been learned by hard
experience is try to make sure it's relevant
um one experience we've had when we've uh for
instance paid for external trainers to come here
is that training material might be really great um
but it doesn't take advantage of the fact that we
kind of know what we do for a living right we know
what our programmers are doing in their day-to-day
work so when we develop trainings we can make
it relevant to what they're actually doing
um so there's it definitely involves an
effort but I think you get a lot of value
by making problems real one simple way of
doing that is just picking out real data
um not using empty cars or Iris which
is what you'll find on online resources
um and that's what we've done in the trainings
we've built in-house um there's actually an open
source package that we've created um specifically
for generating synthetics Edith's data
um so you can make use of that right now
that's the the link on the screen there
and so the last point on training is making
sure it's at the point of need so this is
kind of relating to what I was saying early on
that not everyone is moving towards using our
um all at once so we're doing our best to focus
our training on those who need it we're training
in cohorts rather than trying to train everyone
at once because if you take a training a year
before you actually apply it you've basically
wasted your time because you've forgotten
everything you're using in that time period
so our goal is training at the point of need
the last point I want to make which is going
to lead into ning talking about the business
transition is that while I've talked a lot about
training here learning really isn't about training
um so that relates to that last Point
realistically how you learn is by applying
all of those trainings in your actual day-to-day
work so we want to encourage that kind of context
learning so um and as well as that we also want to
build this culture where you are always looking to
improve how you code so this is speaking back
to this idea of not just making people learn a
language but also becoming fluent in that and
there's a few different things we're focusing
on to try and support that um one is about
building good Frameworks to apply knowledge so
in this environment we're building up making sure
we have good Frameworks where we encourage people
to follow best practice just by those Frameworks
the other is around learning via code review and
seeing other people's code certainly one of
the ways I became a much better R programmer
was by reading code written by someone who is
a better programmer than me and you know I had
I had code that worked but when I reviewed their
code I realized that I could be doing things much
more efficiently and writing code that's much
clearer to read and easier to use in the future
so we're really going to encourage this culture
of code review of looking at code and seeing how
how we can do better um on one connected idea
with that which was actually inspired by the uh
tidy birthdays run by posit was having these
internal hack events which we called hack R
um where we basically took all of those um tools
we're building that Thomas went through and
highlighted issues that we thought people could
take on so we said to our wider data science
audience get involved dot you can improve these
tools and this is another way of highlighting
this idea of an open source culture the idea that
these tools that we're using and developing to do
our work they're not some kind of you know they're
not made by Wizards in this guy they're something
we can work on and improve and we can collaborate
together to lead to better code for all of us
so the last thing which is connected to that is
um learning as teams so I mentioned that we're
not transitioning it once so when we're bringing
teams as a whole into this new environment and
we're going to make sure that they learn together
because they think another way of um learning
quickly is by learning with peers so we're going
to make sure that teams up skilled together
um we're going to support uh people on their
Journey with additional mentoring where we
share Knowledge from Individual to individual
as well so um I'm going to pass now to ning
who's going to talk a bit about how with that
transition for those teams is going to work
thank you very much Kieran yeah so I'll take over
and talk about how we make how we are making our
business transition yeah so as Thomas already
eluded a little bit like from Rose we're a huge
company within roach data Sciences we have over
a thousand employees and we are working on over
200 active molecules so as you can imagine
we have a really diverse group over there
with different skills at a different background
and also we have very diverse type of projects
and in addition to that also as you may
already get a feeling from Thomas Thomas
presentation that like uh for this transition
the scale is very large not only because we
have a larger team but also because uh
there are so many new tools available
out there including the the our packages
as well as some some are noun are tools
including git Docker cloud computing and sname
make this is the beauty of Open Source but also
you can imagine that that introduce additional
complication to our to our business transition
so to ensure a successful business transition
we realize that we really need to make sure
that we can Empower every single project team to
make their own decision and also to make their
own FIFA purpose transition plan we're kind
of thinking that for each project team when
they try to modernize their data science tools
it's sort of like renovating their house so as
we all know that our families decide to renovate
their house each family has their own own needs
some families may spend more time on renovating
kitchen and bathroom and maybe other families
will spend more times on renovating living rooms
and for people who are purchasing a new house they
probably will pick out the new Tools in new
materials when when modeling remodeling their
house similarly for analytical projects we're
thinking that learning this transition Journey
for some of the analytical project teams maybe
they they think that it's valuable to refactor
everything including data process data analysis
Etc and maybe for other teams like their data
pipeline data data processing pipeline is very
stable using the existing tools and they prefer to
keep using the existing tools for data processing
but only adopt the new tools for data analysis and
for brand new projects we think probably likely
the the project team would love to start from the
newer tools so we want to enable each project team
to make a plan that are tailored to their needs
in addition to that similar to remodeling each
family probably have a different uh different like
best timing for their remodeling so for analytical
project we also think that different teams should
have the flexibility to pick up a good timing
for their team to adopt this transition uh likely
that that will be the time frame when they don't
have too many business critical deliverables and
lastly of course different analytical teams have
different access to Thailand pool and resources
although we want to we want to empower each
individual team to make their own decision as
a big organization you can imagine that like it's
probably you will probably create a lot of chaos
if we just go think push things in a decentralized
way and ask everybody to make their own decisions
so as an organization we still need to want to
have some light coordinations across different
teams so at the end of the day we really want
to come up with the adoption roadmap for the
next couple of months uh with that we will have
an under holistic understanding about how many
teams are planning to be onboarded in in certain
time frame and what are their needs what are the
tools they need to learn Etc in addition to that
by having such an adoption roadmap we also think
this is a very good opportunity for us to build
some mechanism to enable iterative feedback to
our to developer team we're hoping that for each
wave of onboarding we there will be a mechanism to
feedback to the to development team so that we can
keep improving our tools as the outboarding goals
so how can we achieve that how can we can come
up with such adoption plan so from Roche we have
a small group of people coming together created
this adapter scheduling team and we work together
with the project teams trying to trying to work
out this adoption plan so like the project teams
will still be the final decision maker but we
have this scheduling team over there trying to
coordinate the onboarding timing across different
teams and also trying to provide consultations to
them for them to understand the truth availability
Etc so what are some of the considerations when we
build up our our adoption roadmap the first thing
is definitely business continuity we want to make
sure that that for each project team they can
identify a couple of good transition timing
for themselves and then we can stay stick with
those good good timings so that we have many we
can minimize business Interruption when doing
this transition secondly we also want to take
this opportunity to enable early collaboration
between the developers and also the users and to
allow iterative development therefore we decided
to start our adoption at a very early stage even
before other tools are 100 ready so we engaged a
small number of users when the the tools are still
somewhat Half Baked and then we ask for feedback
and we also encourage the users to actually
co-create with us by filing bugs or or by even
contributing code back to back to the code base
the other thing we noticed from past experience
is that if we look for early testers uh our early
tester volunteers sometimes we are getting those
like expert users being very active to beat early
testers but those users may not represent
the majority of the user base therefore when
planning out this adoption roadmap we reach out
proactively to different teams and try to try to
include a diverse type of projects and user
base in each wave to represent our user base
in addition to that we also want to make sure
that when we work out this roadmap we we want to
ensure that the trainer and support capacity are
considered we don't want to overload our trainer
or the support team in a short a short time
frame and we want to make sure all the users
get sufficient support and lastly uh and lastly
in the discussion between the scheduling team and
also the project team team the schedule team the
secondary team also provide consultations to help
the uh to help the the project teams to identify
relevant tools and processes to be adopted and
as mentioned not every single study need to
adopt other tools out there and also and also
as mentioned like like uh for early adopters not
all the tools are ready already when teams start
to start to onboarding so this so our scheduling
team also make sure that project teams adoption
timeline allies with our tool availability
foreign so to support this journey as you
can imagine this is not something that can be
driven by a small group of people although it
is a Thomas and Kieran myself presenting here
uh today uh there were there is really a large
community behind who is driving this transition
within rosh and also in the Pharma industry and
we really want to say thank you to everybody who
got involved and I also want to mention that for
many people who are driving those activities they
are not spending 100 of their time on developing
a software or spending 100 of their time on
the change management part rather majority of
people are still working on molecule teams and
they're spending 20 to 30 percent of their time
out driving certain aspects of of our transition
here so what are some of the communities that are
driving this transition within Roche the first one
is definitely the software product teams those are
the developers who wrote our packages who built
the infrastructures who wrote their business tools
we also have a ways of working community and
those are the people who are looking at how
we can integrate the new tools with existing
business processes and they can they also come
up with new guidelines in terms of like ways
of working using newer tools and there is this
romance room aspect scheduling Community a group
of people who interview with the project teams
and provide consultation to the project teams to
come come up with a adoption roadmap and when it
comes to come closer to our project teams on
boarding timeline they will be assigned with
a onboarding coach in the onboarding coach will
help them to identify certain training materials
that are relevant to their team also Point them
to to activities such as hackathons Kira mentioned
and there is a user support Community
answering the questions from the users
and lastly there is a communication Community
who share our who share our adoption progress
to The Wider community and also share
with people what to expect as a Next Step
so where are we right now uh learning Q3 to Q4
last year we welcome a couple of teams joining
us as early adopters we had two waves two waves of
early adopters join us and as mentioned for those
early adopters they when they join us our systems
our tools are not 100 ready yet and they're really
the Trailblazers helping us to test out the tools
and have like early interventions giving feedbacks
Etc and for those two for those project
teams they did have some backup Plans by
using the existing tools because the newer
tools and systems are not 100 ready yet
so in Q2 and Q3 this year we will welcome a couple
of new molecule teams joining us so for those new
molecule teams they are the teams who doesn't
have and they who don't have any Legacy code so
they will start everything from scratch so as you
can imagine they will they will be using the new
Tools end-to-end in end-to-end fashion uh and then
and then they were kind of like uh they will build
this like whole like end-to-end process using our
newer tools and we're really excited to see that
how that how that testing goes and after that if
everything goes smoothly in queue four we expect
to welcome more studies more project teams
joining us for writer robot in that rollout
we will welcome some of the new studies and also
will welcome some other projects who already have
some existing code and they will pick the part
that they might decide to to refactor some of
their code or maybe they just decide to my way
to the new system without refactoring their code
so the journey continues and we're really
really excited to be part of this journey and
hopefully if we got a chance to speak again
in a year or so we can share more good news
so with that I think we are
happy to take any questions
all right awesome thank you so much Roche and
Janine Tech Team lots of wonderful information
tons of questions are coming in I know we've got
about six or seven minutes here so I'm just gonna
jump right in with a couple questions that are
floating to the top so the first one I'm seeing
is what hurdles did you have to overcome for
transitioning from SAS 7B dad to parquet files
for data storage foreign so um yeah so this is
an interesting one because um you know ning just
mentioned you know we'll come back in a year and
we'll tell you success stories so some of this
is you know this is work in progress these are
things we're trying out right now and we haven't
got too much experience of doing it so this
is our Our intention and we you know we have
some uh early teams that are trying out storing in
parquet and so far that that's working really well
um there's obviously going to be attention when
you're doing things in in parquet organ from beat
up because you've got to get sass to be able to
read that files but we're building solutions for
that to be able to happen um but the I mean at
least for natively using them in R um we're quite
optimistic about it because parquet is a really
efficient format and just in our testing it seems
to be that it's going to be a a really good format
for um not only for R but also when we if we use
python python can read parquet natively as well
yeah fantastic any other comments on that one
maybe that's not related to this particular
question but somehow there was a question I
think around whether in the end we still have
to submit these xpt files which is a SAS format
to the FDA and actually indeed that's the case
so this is something we use internally for data
storage and once the data makes it to the FDA
we'll use xbt or maybe if the FDA approves this
new format which is being proposed data set Json
fantastic all right let's move on to question two
can you speak more about the capabilities
shiny offers that you did not have foreign
I think really one key aspect for us was around
this reproducibility um I mentioned um because
for example Tableau or spot fire are stuff that
we used internally it's certainly very powerful
and you can do lots of stuff but if a safety
scientist has such a dashboard and comes with
you this is something I want to have in my CSR
you have basically no idea what how they reach
to that conclusion which subgroup is this
that you see on this plot and how did they
film about Adverse Events Etc so that really was
um for us a big push and also we wanted to have
something which is sort of which Bridges this gap
between the regulatory side of things or kind of
classical tables and the exploratory nature so a
demographic table I showed you basically looks the
same in the app as it would in the final CSR and
thereby it's really a nice match between those two
awesome any other comments on that one or maybe
just to add um so for example I'm not sure how
much statistical analysis functionality Tableau
or spot Fire have they're mostly for visualizing
data but for example until you can fit an mrmm
model which is something fairly complex and I'm
not sure besides SAS and R and which other
languages even can do that and certainly I
don't think any dashboard um app out there has
the capability right right awesome Let's uh move
to question three is there a balance of using
Python and R in your strategy or a wholesale
decision for R if the latter how was that
made so I I think the way to look about it is
um uh the the backbone of our data science is
going to be our so our focus of developing tools
is going to be art so when we look at our resource
of our actual teams building the tools that we're
going to use that's going to be enough and that's
kind of the natural outstretch of that is that
most teams are going to be using are because
that's what the tools have been building but
there will be the ability to use Python where
the problem uh is more easily solved in Python
um as to why are um I I don't know what I don't
know if I want to say anything too controversial
about the differences between harm and python but
I think it's fair to say that as a statistical
piece of software uh in the open source um I would
argue that it is at least equivalent with python
when it comes to statistical problems um and
there's a lot of benefits in terms of just like
what our talent based knew already um yeah I don't
know if anyone else wanted to say anything else so
much yeah I totally agree I feel like right
now probably Academia versus so are the ones
that his own methodology is like many of them are
still developing are in the yeah for example mmrm
Etc yeah so so I think like right now there's
more tools available or for some of the sexism
methods yeah got it all right gonna move
to a popular question that comes up quite
a bit what kind of validation is required for
using R python for clinical trials reporting
um so yeah I think Thomas mentioned already um the
auto validate tool um but I should say that that
come from a history of of collaboration across
the industry um so um there was uh still going
the the r validation Hub uh group um which I
think uh I think is still led by Andy Nichols
uh who it was initially anyway um which looked
at these kind of questions as to um what you
know is is our validated how do you validate and
our package and those kind of questions from it
um so it was kind of a collaboration um taking
these sort of outcomes from that and building
those into our internal Solutions working with
our internal validation teams to get consensus
um and yeah the auto valid AR was a a real late
forward um for us because it was an in-house
solution for validating our packages really
quickly um effectively automatically that's why
it's called to validate um in that we have these
standard measures of an r package quality that we
can use to assess whether we think and our package
can be included and I mean if it doesn't mean
they're standard then we have to do some action
but if if we get on our package and it meets all
those standards then it can be included in our
in our suite of packages kind of straight away
um which is a real what's a real Leap Forward
for us all right we're almost at the hour here so
we're going to go a little fast on these next two
but let's uh squeeze them in if we can the next
one is how much manual work do you have with this
approach between raw data and stdm and atom okay
so the piece from raw data to sttm as I mentioned
we are getting around 80 or so automated which
means you only have to take care of the manual 20
you would go into this Mint app and then basically
say okay this is how I want to map this raw data
into this standard and if you have done it for
one study you can actually then reuse it again
for the next thereby again gaining efficiency
so this should be really fairly streamlined um
then the next step from sctm to Adam that's much
more difficult because it's not just a simple
mapping depending on the analysis you want to
perform Downstream you need to derive certain
things so while we have template code available
that implements sort of our general standards
that will always have to be extensions and this
will be a much larger part of the work compared
to sttm all right anything else on that one
two more questions we'll knock out here pretty
quick all right question six here do you keep
the data sets under Version Control and gitlab
Etc along the code if so do you have these with
large data files yeah but we can just say no no
we don't so we we have a separate solution which I
think Thomas mentioned um using S3 for storing our
data um yeah okay yeah I think it's fair to say if
we did start on GitHub on gitlab yes we would
have a lot of trouble all right well the Roche
ecosystem of apps work with the form of verse
Suite or is it one ecosystem versus the other
it's an interesting way to put it so um more or
less everything I talked about is actually part
of the former verse and the farmer verse is
um you don't have to think about it as kind
of us putting it out there there's lots of
companies contributing various stuff there's
actually our tables for example as part of it
but there's other table packages as well so
it's just kind of a curated list of packages
that adhere to a certain set of Standards
um and that are useful for clinical reporting um
and most of them work independently of each other
so you can mix and match whatever you want to use
and I don't really think there is like a rush kind
of App Suite kind of just the farmer versus
out there and we're using as much as possible
um I think we got uh one more question here
that was quite popular there one that came
in about parquet I think we got to that one
so I'm going to skip it but the next one is
can you please elaborate on the auto validate for
packages I think there was some interest on that
okay um so I I think um yeah so the basic idea
is um it's a tool that can generate reports the
kind of standard reports we need for validation
so those are generated by by the tool and what
you do as a as a as a user as a creator of an
art package is you submit your our package and
you make sure it meets a sufficient quality
check so we have a list of different quality
checks that it does I don't know if the top
of my head what they all are but they include
things like obviously passing cram checks
having uh test coverage past a certain level
um you know all these kind of uh sensible things
that um we think denote on our package being a
sufficient quality and if you pass those then
Auto validate does the rest of the work for you
yeah and that was a great talk by our
colleagues at on Farmer just on this
topic I think like 20 minutes so if that's of
interest to you definitely check that out yeah
and you can uh you can get that talk and
others on the RN Pharma YouTube channel
um I think with that I'm gonna thank all of
you for such wonderful information I know
there's a lot of excitement about the webinar
Thomas that you mentioned that's coming up I
think they can get that is that through the
arc Consortium webinar yes it is and it's
not yet on the website unfortunately okay but
February 24th it's the day teaser exactly all
right yep keep an eye out for that and with uh
with that I will wrap it up thanks for all the
great questions and comments it's great to
see the community come out uh thanks again
for all the effort and time to put this together
especially right after the holidays and with that
I'll uh wish everyone farewell and have a great
day morning evening where you are thanks a lot